Get ready to cry.
A young girl Rita 12 minute 18 second
mark. Get ready to cry
and start balling. Not trying to middle.
I'm just saying get ready. Okay. 12
minutes 18.
>> Beautiful. He said I'm going home. I'm
going.
>> Yep. I don't want to get flagged. So I
got to jump right here. Watch this one
here. Ready? Listen. Story of Rita. Get
ready to start balling.
>> The world to come.
>> Yeah. There's two illustrations that uh
when I read your book, you made me start
to think about when I was growing up.
Okay. I uh my best friend was 11. He had
a sister who was uh 10 and I was nine. I
probably lived at his house more than uh
he did. Uh I was over there for lunch,
dinner almost all the [laughter] time
because my dad was a pastor of a church
at that time. And so I'd cruise the
neighborhood. And uh [snorts] you know
uh the two guys both of us Raj and
myself we uh we would hang out a lot and
you know the girl was in between
>> but we her name was Rita and the fact is
uh you know got to know her talk with
her so on
>> but uh she came down with the disease
when you're 9 years old you don't know
the names of all these diseases but we
just knew that she was sick and then she
got uh
a little sicker and they took her to the
hospital. So, I remember sitting with my
friend on the porch in Chicago and uh we
were sitting there and all of a sudden
uh parents went out and they went to the
hospital and uh to see Rita and then
they would come back. She's she's doing
okay. And uh
>> uh you know, we'd wonder about it. They
wouldn't tell us as kids about her.
Yeah. But uh then uh along the way there
was one Sunday I remember and uh you
talk in your book about things that
happened to you. You got a dream you're
going to talk about somewhere up ahead.
But the fact is you remember it because
it actually happened to you.
>> But I was sitting there and all of a
sudden the phone rang. I remember it
ringing and they came running out the
door. They went to their old Dodto and
they took off and they just said we'll
be back.
>> And when they came back we said uh you
know what happened? And they had tears
in their eyes and they said, "Well, Rita
died today."
>> Okay, now watch. He's young. It's his
buddy's sister. He pretty much grew up
in their home. His father's the pastor.
Rita died. Watch. May our children
outlive us, but rest assured,
Jesus, our Lord, cannot lie. He says,
"The kingdom belong to children." Not
just Christian children. Children, all
human beings are created by Jesus. He
loves all of them. He doesn't see
Muslim, Hindu, Jew, Palestinian. We do
because we're wicked
children who die in innocence under the
grace of the Lord Jesus Christ covered
by the blood of Jesus Christ because to
no fault of their own, they do not know
what they're doing because they don't
have the mental capacity to realize what
sin is. And the Lord meets them where
they're at. Now watch. Listen.
>> All right. Now, I'd never gone to a
funeral when I was nine years old. My
dad was the pastor of the church, but
you know, what do I know about funerals?
>> Yeah.
>> And so, the fact is I wanted this was my
friend, you know, I grew up with her.
So, I thought, let's go see what this
funeral is all about. Church was packed
out. I was sitting on the front row. My
friend Raj was sitting right next and we
were listening and they were doing the
regular stuff, the pastors and all the
choir and all this kind of stuff. But
then there was a little lady
>> and uh she was a strict little lady and
she was a proper little lady and uh but
everybody respected her and she was a
wise biblical lady. Get ready. A woman
who volunteered to stay with Rita in the
hospital
while the parents would go home and
sleep. Watch. The woman gets up. Guys,
get ready to cry. You want a ball? You
want to see how beautiful Jesus is? Man,
pray for me if you love me. Do not
idolize me. Pity me because I have
demonic oppression, fleshly desires that
I struggle with that God will destroy my
flesh and pity me and forgive me and I
never point you to myself, but point you
to Jesus and pray for me and my
daughters and pray for a pray for all
the sick. Watch how beautiful Jesus is.
So I'm stopping so I don't get flagged.
So, you know, YouTube understands it's
copyright law allows for excerpts. Now,
in case I do get flagged, god forbid,
and I have to edit this, it's unedited
on Rumble. It'll be there on edited
Rumble. And she was kind and she had
volunteered to stay with Rita at the
hospital all day, all night when the
parents weren't there. So, Rita always
had somebody to talk with her. and she
was asked to come up at the funeral
service and talk about what happened
when she died.
>> So, man, I am all ears. I want to hear
this one.
>> And she got up there and she said,
>> I was sitting there with Rita and she
had been quiet the whole day, but all of
a sudden, she sat up in her bed
and she said, "Look, look, I see Jesus.
I see the angels."
and she put her head back and she died.
>> Wow.
>> I'm telling you, there with Rita and she
had been quiet the whole day, but all of
a sudden she sat up in her bed
and she said, "Look, look, I see Jesus.
I see the angels."
And she put her head back and she died
there with Rita. And she had been quiet
the whole day. But all of a sudden, she
sat up in her bed
>> and she said, "Look, look. I see Jesus.
I see the angels."
And she put her head back and she died.
>> Wow.
>> I'm telling you, that one knocked me out
right there. Okay. I started thinking
about what she saw and where she was at.
>> Yeah.
>> You see that?
Do you see the goodness of the Lord?
Do you see the beauty of the Lord? The
compassion of the Lord. She was young.
And I'm going to show you where you find
this in scripture. Ready?
Let's go to the scripture here. I got
clips from another video, then we're
going to get into it. But this is to
remind you what it's all about.
What did she experience?
What did she exper? This is Jesus. This
is who our God is.
Cling to him. He is your life. Cling to
him. He is our life. He is my life.
That's why there's a beautiful song. I
wish I could remember the words of
songs, but there's a beautiful song
says, [clears throat]
"There is no other friend.
There is no other friend but you, oh
Lord.
No other brother,
no other sweeter [singing] than you.
There is no other friend.
There is no other friend
but you, oh Lord.
No other brother,
no other sweeter than you. [singing]
Oh,
all my fountains fall in you. Here's
what he says. Okay.
There is no other friend.
There is no other friend but [singing]
you.
Oh Lord,
no other brother.
Here's what he says. [clears throat]
Matthew 19:13-15.
Then some children were brought to him
so they might lay his hands on them and
pray. And the disciples, let's see if
it's large enough. Let me make it a
little larger.
Disciples rebuked them. But Jesus said,
"Let the children alone.
Do not hinder them from coming to me.
For the kingdom of heaven belongs to
such as these.
The kingdom belongs to children. Not
Jewish children, not Palestinian
children, not Indian children, all
children
who to no fault of their own are not
aware of sin
and their responsibility because their
mental faculties are not matured.
They're under the grace of Jesus, the
blood of Jesus, because Jesus's death
procures their redemption. Now, after
laying his hands on them, he departed
from there. Okay? Matthew 19:13-15.
Now, watch her. Matthew 18:105,
you ready?
[snorts]
Exactly. You're going to make me cry
thinking of that song. At that time the
disciples came to Jesus said who then is
greatest in the kingdom of heaven you.
Who's the greatest?
And he called a child to himself and set
before them set him before them as an
example. You want the greatest? He
brings a child like Rita said truly I
say to you unless you are converted and
become like children. See he says be
like a childlike not childish.
you will never enter the kingdom of
heaven.
Whoever therefore will humble himself as
his child, he's the greatest in the
kingdom of heaven, whoever sees one
child in my name receives me. meaning if
you love children for the sake of
Christ, if you love Palestinian children
for the sake of Christ and don't love
them more than Israeli children, if you
love the children in the world, no
matter their race, ethnicity, no matter
if they're male or female, for the sake
of Jesus, because you know, Christ
created them and loves them and owns
them and wants them to be saved,
right?
The Lord will reward you. See the
difference?
Okay. Now, watch here. Focus. Don't be
distracted. Matthew 18:10. See that you
do not despise one of these little ones.
For I say to you that their angels in
heaven continually see the face of my
father who is in heaven.
And I've shared with you two testimonies
from eyewitnesses similar to the story
of that young girl Rita.
John Ankerberg knew the family, knew her
parents, knew the woman. So this was
something he knew.
I'll tell you two stories. We're almost
done, but I want to see something. There
was some I want to show. Yeah. I wanted
to show you this. Why do you think I
have this banner?
Why do you think I have this manner?
Why do you think I have this matter?
Oh, there are no such thing as
Palestinians. I don't care, Bran.
Whether historically the term
Palestinian did not exist, that's not
the point. Today it's called Palestine
and they call themselves Palestinian
because when a Israeli child dies, a
Palestinian child dies under that state
of grace and innocence.
The Lord doesn't say, "Oh yeah, you
Palestinian child to hell. Israeli, come
on in." No, he grabs them by the hands
and says, "You see here, there is
neither Jew nor Greek, neither Jew nor
Palestinian.
There is neither male nor female.
There is neither
free nor slave, for you are all one in
me, and I love all of you equally."
Yeah, because a child's going to know to
hate Jesus. Yeah, I know. What if the
child is taught to hate your mother cuz
she runs a Shia brothel,
right?
There you go.
Why do you think I love this picture?
Cuz this is the real Jesus. The Jesus of
history. The Jesus of the Gospels. The
Jesus who's almighty. The Jesus who's
alive. that Jesus is appearing in dreams
and visions and near-death experiences
and doing miracles that are now being
confirmed through scientific
tests,
right, by people are not necessarily
Christians.